a woman can choose whether or not she
wants to have a child or not do you know
what I mean a man could do what he does
and a woman decides medically a man can
choose yeah but you can't unless you but
I mean like he's not going to carry the
baby you know what I mean like it's not
you know if the woman says you know what
I'm keeping it is what is it she's not
keeping it is what it is what are you
gonna do yeah do you know what I mean
like what's what's harder giving birth
or raising a child raising a child yeah
raising because giving birth isn't
temporary it's like what 12 hours 24
hours yeah but a child is for life so
then by that logic wouldn't it be harder
on the guy no
just forget about it
she's on the hook for 18 years she just
has
just has to also be on the hotel yeah
yeah as well yeah she's raising the
child so I think yeah not if she doesn't
want to be a mother right
it's only if she wants to be a mother
if she doesn't want to be the mother she
wouldn't I guess have the child but if
she didn't